real quick before we get to live calls
in a bunch of other stuff uh the Donald
Trump tax return thing Trump continues
to show no signs of being anywhere near
releasing his tax returns voters want to
see those tax returns there's new data
collected for fortune by the polling
firm morning consult forty five percent
of the 1,900 registered voters that were
polled said that not releasing tax
returns make them view Donald Trump less
favorably and thirty-seven percent of
likely voters said that it also makes
them less likely to vote for Donald
Trump so what you really have to weigh
here Louis right if you're Trump and
you're presented with this data and
you're told hey you know what
thirty-seven percent of likely voters
are less likely to vote for you if
you're not releasing your tax returns if
you're a smart person you're saying okay
well how will that compared to how many
votes I'll lose if I release them and
people find out what the hell is in
there that's the only logic for why you
would not release them given these
numbers isn't it that's that's the only
thing to weigh and uh I'm thinking that
uh that he will release them eventually
uh there's still some time for that but
it's gotta be it's gotta be really ugly
in there because there's no other reason
you would waited this long and a lot of
the more likely possibilities of what's
in there would hurt him charity
donations of one it is one if the tax
returns show that Trump has actually
donated less to charities than he says
forty five percent of republicans and
forty-one percent of independents say
they would be less likely to vote for
Trump as a result of that uh Trump has
made all sorts of claims about how much
he gives away the Washington Post found
evidence that he had given away actually
under ten thousand dollars in charity
since 2008 the effective tax rate the
returns might show that Donald Trump
pays a really really low effective tax
rate if his tax rate ended up being
lower than the average American
forty-one percent of registered voters
and independence say they would be less
likely to vote for him so there could be
some really important and impactful
revelations in those tax returns and we
have to assume at this point
something of what has been mentioned
over the last six months must be in
there let's not forget about uh
political contributions yeah political
type contributions I mean that if that
could really really get messy for him to
those presumably are public but where
they may not be is that Trump may be
donating to intermediaries right which
then could be determined to actually be
donating for example the tons of
Democrats for example which would really
not do well uh with Republican voters
and that's what would be revealed
potentially by Donald Trump's personal
taxes so we'll continue following it but
what we know now is voters want to see
those tax returns I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zip car which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com
slash david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com
slash david